we were looking for the plans and the
intentions
of our enemies there are a lot of ways
to collect intelligence
cameras was my preferred method of
collection
my name is johnna mendez i'm the former
chief of disguise
at cia and before that i was
a photo operations officer at cia
there is an interesting history of using
homing pigeons
to collect intelligence we learned that
we could
put harnesses and cameras on the pigeons
they were very very small the combined
weight of the harness and the camera was
one and a half
ounces the cameras in question
were motorized cameras battery operated
cameras
that would take pictures at
pre-determined
intervals the pigeons must have looked
absolutely
innocent
[Music]
flying over whatever their targets were
one of the beautiful things about a
homing pigeon of course is it will
always come
back and so we would put our lasers
they'd fly over the navy
field we'd bring them back home we'd
develop their film
and the reports are that the precision
in their
photographs was very good at least
as good as what we had in satellite
photography at the time
the minox camera was an amazing
camera for its day it was really the
first
sub miniature camera it was about three
inches long
it would fit in the palm of your hand
you could take pictures
unbeknownst to anybody else you didn't
even need to be a spy to do it because
this was a commercially
available camera you could copy anything
with the minox the people that were
using them
for the foreign agents who had access to
the intelligence
who could get right up next to the
documents and take the picture
agents we're always in a time crunch and
when you get down to the nitty-gritty
when you're actually
taking the photos which is an act of
espionage in most of those situations
it was usually you wanted to get in and
out
and and not be caught doing what you
were doing
it was the toughest part of an operation
we were photographing documents
that would give us the information we
needed typically
they might be minutes from a meeting or
an agenda for a meeting
talking about what our enemies were
getting ready to do next
there are many ways to conceal cameras
this camera is the tessina camera and it
could fit in a cigarette box
another concealed camera was the
matchbox camera
the fun part about the matchbox camera
was that
it was just a box with a camera in it
but it looked like a matchbox and you
could get
back then everybody had these wooden
match boxes and you could
take the label off whatever local
restaurant or hotel
and put it on your matchbox camera
there's another category of body worn
cameras and there were two particular
cameras that were interesting
in that regard one was called a tesena
the other one was called a robot
they were both spring wound but you
could get a group of pictures
without touching the camera and without
physically touching the shutter
mechanism
you could put one in a broad a tie a
belt
a pregnant woman a button they are kind
of
all part of a group of places to put
cameras where they wouldn't be expected
where they would probably not be
discovered and where you'd be able to
covertly take some pictures that
your office thought was necessary and
you'd actuate them by putting your hand
in your pocket by putting your hand on
the strap of your purse
by a hundred different ways and take the
picture
if you're wearing a body worn camera
you're more interested in the place that
you're at
the place that you're going you might
want to see who's meeting with who
who's interacting with who you might
want to see
walking by a building that usually
doesn't have an open door what's
in there there were lots of ways to
conceal
these cameras and we'll use them all
i loved the trip pin camera we only gave
these cameras to our very
very best agents and the one that had
the very best
access these cameras were handmade
the troppal was the smallest concealed
camera that we had
was made by one man it contained an
optic
that was eight tiny tiny pieces of glass
stacked on top of each other
and it couldn't be duplicated anywhere
in the world
the tropel camera could go places that
nothing else could go
and collected just amazing intelligence
for the central intelligence agency
so it wanted to be 13 inches off the
piece of paper
so in the training you teach the agent
that he was the tripod otokachev was a
foreign agent who used our tropel
pen concealment device to a great effect
his case was amazing he was called the
billion dollar spy
and that was because with his
photography he collected the plans and
intentions of the soviet union
as regards its weapon system 10 years
out
its radar systems airborne and on the
ground
he collected he had the schematics he
photographed them
the department of defense at the
pentagon received them and they said
this has saved us
years and years of r d and the money
that we would spend doing the r d
because we have the plans for their next
generation of defensive weapons
the tropel camera was a breakthrough in
size
and the quality of the images that it
would produce
there was really never anything like it
before
and i think there was nothing like it
since
next i'm going to talk about micro dot
technology the micro dot
is a very secure method of communication
a micro dot is taking an eight and a
half by 11
page of text just a regular piece of
paper and reducing it down
and it ends up being about the size
of a period at the end of a sentence
in the international edition of time
magazine
even if someone hands you the magazine
and says there's a micro dot in the
magazine you will never
if you don't know the page in the
paragraph and the sentence
you won't find the micro dot we'd send
it to our foreign agent
and he would know maybe we'd send him a
secret writing message that says
your package will arrive along with time
magazine
we'd have some code detailing the page
the paragraph so i'm holding a couple of
micro dots
that have been concealed behind a stamp
we've
separated the stamp from the sticky
backing and so if you can see there's a
micro dot
in each corner when this stamp is put
onto an envelope
these micro dots become absolutely
invisible the agent would
whatever it was adhered to he'd tear it
out he'd put it in a cup of water the
dot would float off
because it's water soluble glue holding
it and the agent would have a lens
it used to be called a fresnel lens
looked like
a grain of rice he'd get a piece of
cardboard and he'd punch a hole in it
and he'd take his fresnel lens and he'd
put it in the hole and then he'd put
some spit on his finger
pick up the dot put it on the end of the
fresnel lens
and hold it up to the sun or a light and
he could read
an eight and a half by eleven page of
text it was fabulous
it was very secure photography played a
large role in the cold war
some things that were just myths we were
able to prove
some things that were rumors we were
able to disprove
photography is sort of the indisputable
truth very often not that the documents
can't be
wrong but over time and distance
photography
has been able to provide the information
that the intelligence agency
has been after it's an important tool
even though
technology has changed a lot tradecraft
hasn't